Shahs of Sunset start Gigi is known for
being a volatile character on the show
do something I will do something show
you a shot but she says there's more
affecting her mood than people have
realized Gigi has been battling
rheumatoid arthritis since she was just
29 now 35 she's undergoing chemotherapy
to treat it but GG reveals that only
months ago things were much worse how
would you describe that like what is the
pain on a scale of one to ten right now
sitting with you my pain level is about
a five or six
there's days words out of 15 or 20 and
that's sort of a battle that I was
dealing with last year and all
throughout filming my last season was I
was in horrible place and I had never
felt so physically paralyzed like I
couldn't do anything so I did what a lot
of people do to self-medicate I picked
up a bottle and just kept drinking and
it made me feel great
tell me a little bit about your story
because before that you I was an addict
I was um I have 11 years drug free I
started using drugs and I was 11 and a
half and it just kind of progressed very
very fast and I was a full-blown addict
so you know I went into rehab so when
the alcohol abuse I would say picked up
last year
I knew this pattern and I knew what was
happening and I recognized it I was
literally sitting on the ground in my
living room I'm one empty bottle of
Tito's vodka here a bottle of wine here
and some gin and on the other side I
have knives it just came down to the
fight-or-flight at this moment what do I
do in this moment I downed the rest of
that wine and I picked up the phone and
called my friend and said I need you now
what made you
that phone call because everything aside
from my disease everything else in my
life I'm really happy about I didn't
want this disease to be something that
I'm submitting to and giving up you know
even though I really wanted to because I
was just like I'm done I can't Gigi got
treatment and now she wants to give back
she's working with Children's Hospital
Los Angeles on a charity event to raise
money for kids with juvenile rheumatoid
arthritis and helping children is very
personal to the Bravo star what's a
moment that you feel like you won't
forget in this struggle thinking about
having children it is a genetic disease
and thinking that I can pass this on to
my kids or even if I have kids I can't
hold on to them for too long like at
this age I should be starting a family
and I'm even debating if I should
anymore